if you don't have the charisma
or the talent to be a communicator
then make sure that you surround
yourself with
through your team or through your
partners and suppliers
and advertising and marketing and pr
agencies
with people who understand communication
and they know how to deliver this
communication
on your behalf
[Music]
george cotsolios thank you so much for
joining me on 20-minute leaders
welcome thank you very much michael it's
a pleasure to meet you a pleasure to be
here
it's a it's a very very big pleasure of
mine and there's going to be some
interesting lessons that we're going to
learn today together
and so we have to get started because we
only have 20 minutes george
and tell me a little bit about yourself
you're a lot into communications public
relations
in the international spectrum your
business is primarily in
dubai which i'm very excited to be
visiting in just a few hours
so i'm extremely excited to talk to you
here before that
george who are you okay well
i've been in in pi communications for
the last 26
27 years but instead of me starting off
from the beginning i draw the start from
the end because that's a thing where the
interest for
for you and the audience who will
hopefully be spending 20 minutes of
their life to watch uni
having a chat would be more interested
in
and that's because three years ago i had
just turned
50 when i actually
launched my own company in effect i
became an entrepreneur
at the age of 50. you know very common
yes 26 27 years of career and all of a
sudden
i opened my own company but but
the reasons that i did that were purely
existential
because you know i had just been made
redundant
and i needed income to start continue
supporting for myself
and my family so this is when i decided
that
okay it's maybe time to try something of
my own
effectively become my own boss and there
you have it
and i guess lesson number one is
it's never too late you know it's you
know you don't
really need to get your master's degree
or phd
from stanford university and jump on the
bandwagon of entrepreneurship
all at once you know try and pace
yourself
go out experience life get a real job
you know
learn and the time will
come when you are going to feel ready
the circumstances are going to be ready
and the timing is going to be the right
one for you
to go and reach out for your dreams
now yes sorry you wanted to ask
something michael
yeah i i have to get into the mindset of
50 years old existential threat
you know you are you need to to
bring income for your for yourself and
your family and you're saying you know
why don't i start a business why don't i
become an entrepreneur this is something
that a lot of
you know 21 22 year olds say not so many
50 year olds i think that's pretty
inspiring so i'd love to just understand
a little bit better
your thought process as you're making
that big decision
that big leap yeah well i mean the the
number one
thing that i believe uh any entrepreneur
must have
no matter what age he or she is or how
old they are and feel
is passion and experience
and deep understanding and knowledge
of the area of the sector that they are
about to embark on
so in my case as you introduced me
earlier i have a long experience in pr
communications journalism and that's
what i was trained to do and that's what
i've been doing for a quarter of a
century
or more during my career
and i took that passion
and i turned it into my own starter
now the good thing was that not
only did i continue to do
what i knew very well doing for such a
long time
but in a way i rediscovered my
mojo for a lack of a better experience
wow and that happened because
my first clients when i opened my
company
happened to be a young
aspiring tech startup entrepreneur
back in dubai where i am still um
this guy had a long experience
working for other startups until
he took a decision one day to open his
own
health tech starter company he had the
knowledge the experience
and the passion which he conveyed to me
you know there were days that we were
having long arguments about petty things
but that helped me understand and
realize how
passionate he was feeling about his own
company
and i guess that is the second lesson uh
michael for our viewers a day
it's without the passion
and without the experience having done
the journey
before not necessarily as an
entrepreneur but working
for others it's going to be a difficult
thing it's going to be
dangerous it's not going to be as fluent
as right we will feel once you have this
passion inherently inside you
right so you're talking so you're trying
that experience was pit was pivotal in
your ability to streamline your your
work
to know what you're doing to be fluent
with your business and to actually be
successful in it because
you're actually providing value so what
what what what is the business that you
started as an entrepreneur
at 50 years old and what skills did you
bring with you from your previous work
life
so what so what i do you know is
basically
um developing content developing
messaging developing positioning
developing campaigns public relations
campaigns that generate
what we call in my language by industry
and
publicity so it's not like advertising
where you go and pay uh time magazine or
new york times
or golf news who's closer to where i
live
in order to place an advert in the pages
this is probably that you earn through
public relations tactics
and that is what i do and public
relations
is very very important in fact your
question brings me
to the third lesson i want to sort of
share with our audience today
so having the um the timing right for
you to open it is number one
then having the experience and the
passion to do it
is number two but then being able to
communicate
right your passion and communicate
this this vision of yours effectively
across your state called the universe
which once you launch your company is
going to be
comprising a very diverse group of
people including your employees
including your b2b partners including
your b2c consumers who you want
them to download your app including your
regulators stakeholders
government stakeholders all the way to
investors
you need to be able to communicate
these to the different audiences
and basically that is the third lesson
if you don't have the charisma or the
talent
to be a communicator then make sure that
you surround yourself
with through your team or through your
partners
and suppliers and advertising and
marketing and pr agencies
with people who understand communication
and they know how to deliver this
communication
on your behalf right so you know i'm
surrounded by a lot of young
entrepreneurs communication is not i
i wouldn't say that it's our forte and i
think that it comes coming from more of
an engineering background and being
excited about the product and technology
is one thing but like you're mentioning
our success it often depends on our
ability to communicate
and it doesn't really matter how good
our product is if we're not able to
to communicate that it's what
makes uh differentiates a successful
startup from a failure i mean
there's plenty of studies out there but
one that has really stuck with my mind
is that out of the hundreds
start-up companies that they are
launched
globally 97 will fail
just three of them will make it a
successful exit
or a successful acquisition or maybe go
to have an ipo
just three percent and i believe firmly
that the key quality the differentiating
factor
between those who make it and those
don't
is the ability to successfully
communicate
the vision the passion the solution
and the technology that because
technology is pretty much the same
solutions are pretty much the same
because we've got similar problems right
it's how you communicate your solution
to the various
stakeholders you want to engage with
that differentiates you
from the crowd michael you just
mentioned you work for a vc
i've got a vc client who is actually
based out of greece
they deal with a lot of european as well
as dubai and uae based
startups and that single thing he keeps
telling me that he and his team are
looking
into a young text up entrepreneur
who sends them their decks for
evaluation
in order for the fund to invest in them
is to be able to communicate effectively
that is the number one because the
solution
is here today in one shape and form
trust me a year or two down the line
the package is going to look differently
100 so so george give me a little bit of
insight what it means to communicate
effectively because
obviously it's a it's a lifelong skill
that that takes a lot of expertise and a
lot of experience but
but there must be some things that we as
young entrepreneurs can embrace
to be more cognizant of it and to really
make sure that that the other side is
understanding
the value that we're trying to provide
so what are some ways that we as young
entrepreneurs
can better communicate effectively
absolutely
this is a process michael it doesn't
happen overnight you need to
have in place resources
budgets and a robust plan
that eventually is going to take you
there eventually going to help you
communicate better let me start what
with the three
basic steps of the process the first uh
basic step is to be able
to uh let's say set
your true north okay
what do i mean by that you need to be
able
to develop a positioning for your tech
startup
an overarching positioning that
resonates simultaneously
with every single different
target group that you are trying to
engage with
and once you have this solid in your
mind
then what you need to do is to develop
what we call in our in our
business a key messaging platform
which is imagine like a house okay i'll
try to
i try to make it a picture for you
imagine you've got a house
there is a roof on top of the house
inside this roof this is where your
overarching positioning statement about
your humble
tech startup is okay which actually
tells where you want to go why is the
solution that you are developing why
you are the best person and your best
company
to bring it to market okay right and
under
it's under this uh let's say roof
you've got windows okay now depending on
the complexity
of your tech startup you are going and
the number of
stakeholder audiences that you want to
impact
you will have an equivalent number of
windows
right right the case is that i have
dealt with it and i have dealt with
startups from the health tech industry
from the last mile delivery
industry from the fintech industry
the food industry uh e-commerce you name
it i've done it all
the the the the number of target
audiences varies between
three and five depending on the complex
the complexity
the three key audiences are usually
b2b which means these are the
the partners that you want to influence
to uh to to bring to bring over
number two is the consumer you know the
people that they are going to be making
use
of your application whether you're a
health tech or a food delivery app
and the third is the investors because
startups you know
they need to encourage investment from
vcs for private eco defense from
individual investors and so on and so
forth
so for each of these three let's say
key target audiences then you need to
have
another opening statement
that resonates uniquely to them
okay and once you communicate
uniquely to them then you need to have
what we call
a series of three no more key messages
that bring that sub opening
to life it sounds a little bit
complicated if it's not very clear
please ask me to explain it again no no
it's perfectly clear and the thing that
makes
that makes most sense is this is the the
fact that you need to make it unique to
the person that you're talking to i
think i'm assuming that one of the
biggest pitfalls of
entrepreneurs especially young
entrepreneurs is that you're using the
same messaging the same deck
the same pr release to the every single
person
but that's not necessarily the message
that they want to hear and you have to
stand out from the crowd
you got it exactly right you know the
message that the investor wants to hear
is completely different to the one that
the
consumer wants to hear and definitely
not similar
to the one that the b2b audience comes
to here right
so that is the philosophy that i have
brought and i have developed
to communicate to to develop rather the
messaging
for my tech startup clients so that is
the first step of the process
once you've got this all done and dusted
and signed off by the client
then the next step is what we call media
training
and messaging delivery then we sit with
the tech startup founder and co-founders
and and owners and we take them through
a rigorous for our session
the last few months we've been doing it
over zoom but previously
of course it was uh physical meetings
where
we have on the back the job you know the
the
you know the deck that we have developed
for the messaging and then we take them
through a process
which includes a number of a real-life
case studies explaining to them the
difference between a good interview and
a bad interview
they would take them through practical
sort of
workshops where we we try them you know
how they answer
a question before they go through the
trade and
then they answer it at the end so
because you know as we said earlier
communication is key you know yeah it's
great to have the
the positioning right the messaging
right but
if you are if you don't have it
naturally
you if you are not a natural
communicator then this media training
helps people to to help them to organize
their thoughts
and help them to sort of know what to
say
when to say it and what not to say which
is also also very very important
no no that sounds a lot that sounds very
important and and the third step
is engagement right so once we've got
the messaging right
once we've got the training all sorted
then
it's time to engage with our universe
stakeholder universe
and that includes a number of
stakeholders it could be for instance
a panel discussion over zoom where the
tech startup enterpreneur will go
and be part of a panel so he needs to
have his messaging
there available in his mind and be able
to deliver the right message
it could be a tedx speech you know being
there 10 15 minutes
talking about the pro the solution the
problem but also
making it relevant to his company right
right or it could be a media interview
a live tv or live radio which is very
very unforgiving by the way
because if you say something live on
telly on radio and it's wrong
then you know halas it's it's not going
as long obviously
but also what we do as as a company as a
business is then we package this
information depending on the occasion
and into what we call press releases or
feature articles and then we take this
written information and we work with our
media contacts
to make sure that we place them in the
magazines in the newspapers in online
publications
and so forth and that's how we start
developing
the visibility the awareness
that i am here i am the owner of this
company my company does
x y and z we are solving this problem
and that's how eventually you are going
to get noticed
otherwise it doesn't matter if you have
the best solution
as long as nobody knows it it's not
going to be good enough
i love it george that was inspiring and
fascinating thank you so much for
sharing from your experience i think
most of all it's just
it's inspiring to see somebody that that
is so passionate about what they do and
your passion stands out from every word
that that you said here today
so thank you very much for that i want
to thank you for being so generous with
your time
and before we leave i have to ask you
for three words that you would use to
describe yourself
oh ouch okay
you're going there okay i would say
curious is one
and and that comes from my journalism
background i started as a journalist
and journalism pi is very very sort of
relevant in a way because
if you know if you know how to write as
a journalist then you know how to write
about everything so curious is one and i
would also say
uh inquisitive which is pretty much
similar to to curiosity so that's two
uh you want the third one as well well
the third one i think i'm going to grant
myself which is passionate because
i've done i've done over 250 of these
episodes and
and i i can i can see very clearly the
passion that you're bringing towards
this and it's just remarkable so thank
you for that
wow thank you so much thank you so much
michael thank you